let's see how to build and launch an  asp.net core app from google cloud shell  first step class shell from Google Cloud  console by default class shell has done  a command-line tool already installed  let's create a folder for our app and  use Neal - T web command to create a new  web app this creates a number of plans  for our web app let's open Orion clutch  shots browser-based editor and edit  program dot CSV file and add use URL  line to make sure the web app binds to  port 8080 save  and now run net restore to download the  nougat dependencies or our app  finally execute run command to compile  and run our application  now do a web preview and us without the  core app now runs on Linux in the cloud